le 19/20 continue tout de suite avant
les titres le point sur la prise
d'otages au siège de la société roc ca
la défense à paris jean-jacques bazille
vous êtes en direct tout vient de se
terminer à l'instant oui tout à fait
eric tout s'est achevé ya à peu près 15
minutes on entendu un grand fracas des
bris de vitres les forces de police ont
dû intervenir d'urgence dans l'une des
pièces où était retenu en otage le pdg
de rang 2 et rocks tout ce qu'on sait
que vous de tout ce qu'on sait pour
l'instant c'est que le pdg a été blessé
lors de l'intervention une légère
blessure apparemment au côté fera
toujours est il que maintenant
l'opération cette prise d'otages qui
avait débuté je vous le rappelle à 12h15
s'est achevée après pratiquement sept
heures de négociations le quartier la
défense était complètement cerné un
avocat était intervenu pour aider le
preneur d'otages a discuté avec le pdg
ainsi que son directeur général et ainsi
que deux secrétaires vous nous rappeler
jean raclée raison de son rapt c'était
un ancien employé qui réclamaient des
indemnités plusieurs années après son
licenciement ce sera alors tout à fait
ce cette personne était ingénieur à la
société ranxerox il a été licencié il ya
neuf ans pour paraît-il une faute
professionnelle
et c'est seulement aujourd'hui qu'il est
devenu venus réclamer des indemnités de
licenciement au moment du refus il a
sorti un fusil à canon scié
merci jean jacques bazié en direct de la
défense l'information en direct c'est
sur l'a3 voici maintenant les titres de
ce journal la fin du monopole de
l'essence sur les autoroutes françaises
une grande surface a ouvert une station
service sur l'a31 entre troyes et dijon
conséquence immédiate les prix ont
baissé notre invité ce soir michel
edouard leclerc crise ouverte au rpr ou
la direction de jacques chirac et
publiquement contesté par deux hommes
forts du mouvement sur le pasqua et
philippe seguin ont décidé aujourd'hui
de faire alliance pour proposer un
nouveau rassemblement le sommet du
comecon à sophie à l'union soviétique
propose de régler les échanges en
devises fortes dé 1991 ce constat
accablant aujourd'hui des activités de
l'organisation économique des pays de
l'est
enfin en basket le ca saint-etienne
devrait abandonner le professionnalisme
victimes du boycott des autres clubs
saint-etienne va prononcer sa
liquidation judiciaire dans les
prochains jours à l'étranger l'union
soviétique propose donc de régler les
échanges économiques entre les pays
de l'est en 2000 forte dès 1991 le
dollar le yen le marques vont remplacer
les roubles au sein du comecon cet
ersatz de marché commun européen dont le
bilan d'activité est plutôt accablant où
est le sommet du comecon qui s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui à sofia et qui
accable littéralement les années
précédentes d'activité sommet
exceptionnel donc d'autant qu'il
réunissait les premiers ministres nommés
en roumanie en pologne en
tchécoslovaquie chou en hongrie après
les derniers bouleversements en europe
de l'est
pierre babey il y a un an seulement ils
étaient pour la plupart en dissidence ou
dans l'opposition ou même en prison
c'est dire que les participants au
sommet du comecon veulent tout sauf la
duplication du passé le soviétique riche
kof a beau tenter de retenir le
mouvement il ne peut rien contre les
volontés centrifuge un exemple la
proposition hongroise de créer avec la
pologne la tchécoslovaquie rien moins
qu'un marché commun mais à trois
seulement trois pays dont l'outil
industriel n'est pas trop délabré et qui
ont décidé qu'au bout de leurs réformes
il y aura finalement l'ouverture sur une
économie de marché à l'occidentale bond
no rodrigo devenir un membre donc mal
dtp et de marché le but inavoué pour
l'instant des trois cavaliers seuls
c'est bien évidemment de disjoindre leur
cas de ceux plus désespérée de leurs
frères du comecon et le japon qui ne s'y
trompa propose ce soir même à la hongrie
et à la pologne une assistance pas une
aide nuances de près de 2 milliards de
dollars sur 3 ans et 3 ans ô coïncidence
c'est précisément le délai que se fixent
des autorités hongroises pour raccrocher
leurs wagons encore poussif au train
plus rapide de l'économie du marché
mondial nouvel élément de la lutte
internationale contre la drogue la
police espagnole a démantelé une bande
de trafiquants de drogue appartenant au
cartel de medellin arrêtant au total 13
colombien c'était donc aujourd'hui à
madrid
au total également été saisis 2 178 kg
de cocaïne tout de suite le point sur
l'actualité internationale voici les
traits les gammes
télégramme de l'étranger pardon préparer
et commenté par jean philippe dire
13h35 cet après-midi la navette columbia
cuite la floride avec trois semaines de
retard pour une mission spatiale de dix
jours objectif de l'équipage trois
hommes et deux femmes déployer un
satellite de communications militaires
et tenter de récupérer vendredi un
satellite d'observation scientifique en
orbite depuis six ans de la taille d'un
autobus second satellite devait retomber
sur terre fin février le principal
mouvement nationaliste lituanien appelle
les habitants de vilnius à manifester en
masse pour la liberté et l'indépendance
le jour de l'arrivée de gorbatchev le
numéro un soviétique est attendu demain
ou après demain dans la capitale de la
république battre
il veut convaincre le parti communiste
local de revenir sur sa déclaration
d'indépendance du pc soviétique
les nationalistes lituanien appellent
eux au retrait des troupes de l'armée
rouge
le bras de fer est engagé à la demande
du nouveau gouvernement panaméen les
forces américaines ont encerclé la
résidence de l'ambassadeur du pérou et
au panama
des soldats appuyés par des véhicules
blindés veulent arrêter deux
collaborateurs du général noriega
réfugié dans l'ambassade
d'autre part le président guillermo
endara a demandé à george bush une aide
économique d'urgence de 2 milliards de
dollars
enfin suite des violences interethniques
en inde
la police a ouvert le feu aujourd'hui
sur les manifestants musulmans à
srinagar sans au moins deux personnes et
manifestants protester contre les
brutalités policières
selon un porte-parole du gouvernement la
répression a déjà causé la mort de 15
personnes en deux jours
en france la fin du monopole de
l'essence sur les autoroutes les
compagnies pétrolières vont devoir
aligner leurs prix sur ceux des grandes
surfaces qui semble décidé à enlever ici
et là la victoire de la concurrence
premier exemple sur l'a31 entre troyes
et dijon alain michel edouard leclerc il
a inauguré ce matin sa première station
service sur autoroute une véritable
brèche ouverte dans le système de
monopole des grandes compagnies
pétrolières alors plusieurs questions
maintenant pourquoi at on attendu si
longtemps avant de laisser place aux
grandes surfaces sur les autoroutes
quelle est la finalité de leur
implantation
nous en parlons dans un instant avec
michel edouard leclerc qui est notre
invité mais tout d'abord retour sur ce
monopole jusqu alors officieux mais bien
réel quelle est la législation qui a
permis pendant des années aux grandes
compagnies pétrolières de régner en
maître sur les autoroutes
quelques éléments de réponse avec
caroline sièges il existe 300
stations-service sur les autoroutes
françaises
sept seulement n'appartiennent pas à des
raffineries un monopole que pierre
bérégovoy essayer de briser ancêtres
20,8
lorsqu il autorise les particuliers à
concourir aux appels d'offres ceux ci
sont gérés par la direction des
hydrocarbures du ministère de
l'industrie
en fait c'est l'état qui a le monopole
du choix certaines compagnies
pétrolières laisse même entendre
aujourd'hui que leclerc aurait bénéficié
des faveurs du gouvernement faveur
qu'elles ont peut être peur de voir
s'éloigner une station sur l'autoroute
est soumise à une stricte réglementation
ouvrir 24 heures sur 24 et 365 jours par
an proposée tous les types de carburant
et avoir de très grandes cuves en plus
il faut payer une redevance aux sociétés
d'autoroutes beaucoup trop de charges
pour les particuliers qui dans ces
conditions ne sont plus compétitifs les
grandes surfaces pratiquer les prix les
plus bas
car elle travaille avec peu de stocks et
des marges réduites elles risquent
beaucoup sur les autoroutes
celles ci sont pour l'instant squatté
par les gros total elf esso et shell ces
compagnies pétrolières se taisent
aujourd'hui elle refuse tout commentaire
se sentir est elle menacée sur leur
terrain leur seule réponse
elles ne veulent pas polémiquer avec
leclerc l'un des responsables de ces
compagnies pétrolières a cependant
déclaré que cette inauguration
aujourd'hui était un coup de pub fait
bleu réalisé avec la complicité des
pouvoirs publics c'est vrai que vous
avez été soutenu dans ce dossier oui
tout à fait nous avons été soutenus par
pierre bérégovoy par le ministre de
l'industrie et puis permanent mené hier
tu qui préconisait plus de concurrence
sur les autoroutes il faut savoir que
depuis 1985
rien ne s'opposait à ce que nous allions
sur les autos simplement il y avait une
petite timbale une petite tambouille
autour de la direction de carburant et
le marché se passait entre copains alors
la nouveauté c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
pouvoirs publics ont mis les pieds dans
le plat et en l'occurrence les pieds
c'est nous alors vous avez gagné une
victoire là aujourd'hui vous avez réussi
à ouvrir une station service se retourne
mais vous avez décidé de ne pas vous
arrêter là vous voulez maintenant ouvrir
des centres commerciaux
voyez d'abord ça fait quinze ans que mon
père a commencé à se battre pour obtenir
des rabais sur les carburants et des tas
de procès bon c'est la suite la
conséquence d'une énorme bataille
alors quand on dit que c'est que de la
pub je vous dire c'est sacré risque et
puis il y avait des amendes à la clé il
ya des milliards de centimes d'amande à
la clé donc les centres leclerc ont pris
ce risque est derrière eux il ya des
carrefours des hauts champs d euros
marchés qui vont s'engouffrer
l'objectif c'est pas d'ouvrir une
station vitrine ses deux dents d'ouvrir
un petit peu partout sur les autoroutes
pour faire baisser les prix
nous y avons intérêt aussi un enjeu
commercial fabuleux ce sont des marchés
captifs ce sont des marchés où nous
pouvons faire baisser les prix tout en
gagnant de l'argent je vous parlais de
faire baisser les prix comment se fait
il que sur les autoroutes en france
laissant soit si cher aujourd'hui parce
qu'il ya pas de concurrence il ya très
peu de concurrence vous savez très bien
que vous prenez une autoroute qu'à une
en scène succès d'une autre que le
marché est partagé
et comme très peu de consommateurs
veulent quitter l'autoroute passé le
péage pour aller acheter moins cher en
hypermarchés ou chez des indépendants
leur essence celle arnaque permanent
vous engager à ce que l'essence au même
prix sur l'autoroute que dans vos centre
commercial un peu partout l'annoncé je
ne peux pas faire parce que sur
l'autoroute ya les surcoûts il faut 24
heures sur 24
je vous rappelle que nous n'avons pas
leurs grelots dimanche en tant qu
hypermarchés il faut ouvrir 365 jours
sur 365 et des équipements sanitaires à
faire même pour les gens qui me prêtent
pas de carburant
et puis il ya aussi une redevance à
verser aux sociétés d'autoroutes je vous
prie de croire qu'on va négocier
quelle est la prise de participations de
l'état aucune
sur le prix de l'essence vendue en ligne
sur les autoroutes à pardon c'est sûr
que le des automobilistes restent les
vaches à lait de la fiscalité mais tout
le monde paye l'impôt va jouer dans les
grandes compagnies pétrolières comme les
grandes surfaces qui fait la différence
de prix c'est quand même nos marges
alors dernier point vous avez mené la
bataille pour les pharmacies vous a mené
la bataille pour l'essence sur les
autoroutes quel est votre prochain
combat royal à plat elle a plein autour
de la voiture déjà sur l'autoroute
ils ont les gens ne s'arrêtent pas que
pour prendre de l'essence ils veulent
aussi manger ils veulent boire
donc nous on a ouvert une petite
supérette à côté qui pourra peut-être
s'agrandir par la suite ou de vendre
jusqu'à 50% moins cher l'eau minérale le
coca cola le note le marque donc mais
derrière il ya tous les services
bancaires les services de voyages et
services de spectacle ça lui prenait le
bouquin de françois de closets toujours
plus dans chaque page vous avez un
secteur corporatiste à chatouiller mais
trop sûr de gagner de toute façon ce
soir pas tout cas il faut voir un petit
peu ce qu'on fait si donc merci de
toutes ces précisions michel edouard
leclerc toutes les marques citées sur
cette antenne était parfaitement libre
de droits politiques
le coup de théâtre et les renversements
d'alliances au sein du rpr charles
pasqua et philippe seguin ont décidé de
présenter aux assises nationales une
contribution commune en vue je cite de
renouveler le mouvement est de son côté
jacques chirac soutient alain juppé dans
le projet politique qu'il présentera aux
acision ce février prochain le maire de
paris qui vient aussi et d'annoncer sa
candidature à la présidence du mouvement
on est bien loin de l'union de
l'opposition éric perreault c'est une
véritable déclaration de guerre contre
jacques chirac et alain juppé le
secrétaire général du rpr communiqué
publié par charles pasqua et philippe
séguin ne ménage pas on essaie la
direction du mouvement
incapable je cite de tracer un nouvel
objectif est de redonner confiance aux
français jacques chirac n'a pas attendu
pour contre attaquer cet après midi le
maire de paris publié lui aussi un
communiqué pour affirmer qu'il est
toujours candidat à la présidence du rpr
et aussi pour soutenir alain juppé si
jacques chirac a réagi si vite c'est
qu'il prend très au sérieux l'offensive
pasqua séguin
la popularité de l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur est en effet très grande à
l'intérieur du parti
aussi bien chez les militants que dans
les instances dirigeantes et l'alliance
avec philippe séguin l'un des principaux
responsables de rénovateur risque de
peser très lourd lors du congrès du
mouvement qui doit avoir lieu le 11
février prochain et qui promet en tous
les cas d'être chaud
voilà pour le dossier politique mais
tout de suite le tour de france de
l'actualité en bref grâce aux images de
nos stations régionales commentaire
nathalie darrigrand
les oeuvres d'henri matisse voler ici en
décembre dernier ont été retrouvés
aujourd'hui à nice le cambrioleur un
jeune toxicomane bien connu dans la
ville a été arrêté après un simple
contrôle de routine les huit toiles du
maître était simplement posé sur le
siège arrière de sa voiture
le maire rpr de toulouse jacques gosso
et gérard beauty et resteront en prison
la chambre d'accusation a refusé ce soir
leur remise en liberté
les deux hommes ont été inculpés et
écroués à la mi-décembre 89 dans la
sphère des fausses factures de nancy
il n'y avait pas le feu aujourd'hui à
paris et pourtant plusieurs centaine de
sapeurs pompiers sont venus manifester
dans la capitale
objectif le ministère de l'intérieur
leurs revendications une amélioration de
leurs conditions de travail et de leur
niveau de vie
le cargo panaméen l'obtenir ci est
arrivé ce matin au port de brest la
cargaison d'orge qui continuait toujours
à se consumer a pu enfin être débarqué
reste maintenant à déterminer les causes
de l'incendié qui s'était déclaré dans
les cales du bateau jeudi dernier les
géo du club med devront désormais avoir
le pied marin leur pdg gilbert trigano
en effet et ce matin baptisé son dernier
village de vacances le plus grand
paquebot à voile du monde
l'enjeu créer un nouveau type de
croisière four je cite les riches actifs
dommage pour les autres
en sport les verts ne sont décidément
plus ce qu'ils étaient il s'agit cette
fois de basket le ca saint-etienne
boycotté en début de championnat par les
autres clubs de nationale 1b va devoir
renoncer au professionnalisme et bien
sûr à ses ambitions un littéralement en
ruine et par cette affaire de boycott le
ca saint-etienne devrait prononcer sa
liquidation judiciaire dans les
prochains jours un véritable gâchis
sportif et financier de l'union
franck giraud un panier pour le club de
saint-etienne
mais un panier percé pour ses finances
hier les dirigeants du club se déclare
en état de cessation de paiement
pour eux il faut deux millions deux cent
mille francs pour finir la saison
mais cette fois c'est trop la
municipalité de saint-etienne ne veut
pas accorder une nouvelle fois sa
garantie pour un emprunt basket a
parfaitement sa place à saint-etienne
mais il n'est pas sûr que nous puissions
assurer une équipe avec des comme ça se
passe aujourd'hui avec des vedettes qui
coûte très cher nous avions droit d'être
ambitieux l'on peut être un peu
ambitieux peut-être un tout petit peu
impatient mais ça c'est un petit détail
l'élément majeur de la situation c'est
uniquement uniquement le boycott point
de départ de cette situation ces deux
hommes cécile rockeur américain
naturalisé français et terry tard paix
franco américain le règlement prévoit
qu'ils doivent être naturalisée depuis
trois ans pour jouer en championnat ce
qui n'est pas le cas
conséquence jusqu'au 11 novembre le case
gagne tous ses matches mais par forfait
de ses adversaires
la salle est vide un sacré manque à
gagner pour le club si la liquidation
judiciaire est prononcée
sept joueurs un entraîneur et deux
administratifs resteront sur la touche
le basket stéphanois de haut niveau sera
définitivement enterré en ski c'est la
suissesse vreni schneider qui a enlevé
cet après-midi le sound hinterstoder en
autriche comptant pour la coupe du monde
trois officiers les deux suissesses aux
cinq premières places mais où sont donc
passés les françaises et en fait la
seule classe et à la septième place il
s'agit de béatrice filiol beaucoup de
concurrentes ont chuté en raison des
mauvaises conditions météorologiques et
seuls 15 concurrents tente ou dans la
course se sont classés voilà la course
de retour maintenant sur la première
information que nous avons développées
au cours de ce journal la prise d'otages
au siège de la société rank xerox à la
défense à paris prise d'otages qui s'est
terminée vous le savez sans faire de
victime grave bien que j'apprenne à
l'instant par une dépêche que le pdg de
la société monsieur olivier gouez ça a
été sérieusement blessé par l'homme
qu'il avait donc pris en otage ainsi que
quatre autres personnes cet après midi à
puteaux l'homme en question âgé de 45
ans daniel viel est sain et sauf il a
été interpellé bien sûr par les forces
de l'ordre
ils réclamaient je vous le rappelle le
paiement d'une prime de licenciement qui
remontait à neuf ans c'est la femme
cette édition dans un instant la météo
complète de florence klein le programme
de la soirée sur l'a33 20h35 ainsi d'une
terreur à bord avec jean pierre aumont
et à 22h35 soir 3 les infos présenté par
philippe de syndication et puis
j'apprends à l'instant les rapports du
tiercé quinté plus qui se disputait
aujourd'hui à vincennes et fallait jouer
le 11 le 13/09 dans le tiercé cela vous
rapporte 3557 francs gelé découvrant un
temps que vous et puis le quinté plus il
fallait jouer le 11 le train
le 9 le 5 le 15 et si vous avez joué les
cinq chevaux dans l'ordre pour 10 francs
vous avez gagné 325000 et 41 france
j'espère que vous faites partie des
heureux gagnants nous vous retrouverons
demain à 19 heures pour une nouvelle
édition du 19 20
excellente soirée je serai bonne soirée
pour ça
oui
et